أظهر اختبار الرئيس بايدن نتائج إيجابية
لكوفيت مرة أخرى
بعد إجراء آخر اختبار سلبي أمس ،
وعاد اختبار مستضد إيجابيًا هذا
الصباح ، يقول طبيب الرئيس إن السيد
بايدن يشهد انتعاشًا من باكس
لوفيد للدواء الذي كان
يتناوله للتعافي من
الطمع في المرة الأولى.
قام الرئيس بالتغريد اليوم للناس اليوم ، لقد
أثبتت إصابتي بالطمع مرة أخرى ،
يحدث هذا مع أقلية صغيرة من الناس
ليس لدي أي أعراض ، لكنني
سأعزل من أجل سلامة كل من
حولي ، ما زلت في العمل وسنكون كذلك
عد إلى الطريق قريبًا ومعي الآن
الدكتور بيتر هوتس عميد المدرسة الوطنية
للطب الاستوائي في
كلية بايلور للطب أه دكتور هوتز سعيد
لرؤيتك مرة أخرى لم أرك
منذ وقت طويل ولكن من الجيد أن ألحق به.
ما رأيك في هذا هل يجب أن أه كنّا على علم
بقلق بالغ حيال
هذا البيت الأبيض يقول إن
الرئيس لا يعاني أه أي
أعراض تسمعها عن
هذه الارتدادات أهذه الارتدادات هذه  من
وقت لآخر أه ما هي أفكارك
حول هذا
الأمر ، فأنت تعلم أنه من المحتمل أن يكون
أكثر شيوعًا مما نفهمه حاليًا
في
التجارب السريرية لـ paxolovid التي تم إجراؤها
قبل
متغيرات omicron هي بالتأكيد
المتغيرات الفرعية
اللاحقة.  سيحدث حوالي واحد إلى اثنين في المائة
من الوقت ، لكننا
نسمع عن العديد من الحالات ، وبصراحة تامة
أه انتعاش آه بعد الحب
حدث لي ، حدث لتوني فوشي
دكتور
فوسي ولذا لم يكن مفاجئًا جدًا أن
لقد حدث هذا في الواقع منذ يومين ،
لقد حذرت من عدم الشعور بخيبة أمل كبيرة
إذا حدث أيضًا للرئيس
بالضبط النسبة المئوية
للأشخاص الذين يعانون من
انتعاش تم تحميله بعد دفع الضرائب ، سمعت الرقم
20 ، ولا أعرف مدى صحة ذلك
ولكنه بالتأكيد أعلى
مما تم إجراؤه في
التجارب السريرية الأصلية وأعتقد أنه قد يكون
جزئيًا بسبب هذه المتغيرات الفرعية الفرعية الجديدة ،
فهناك الكثير من تكاثر الفيروسات ،
وبالتالي هناك  المزيد من الفيروسات للتغلب عليها عن طريق
تناول الدواء المضاد للفيروسات ، وهناك
دراسة جديدة تفيد بأن
مجموعات الأمراض المعدية بجامعة كاليفورنيا سان دييجو تبحث
في أنها تظهر أنه ليس بسبب
مقاومة الأدوية الناشئة ،
لا يزال الفيروس
حساسًا للباكسلوفيد عندما يحدث الارتداد.
أعتقد أن
الأمر يتعلق بالتعرض للدواء حيث لا يوجد
دواء كاف يدخل
الخلايا
خلال دورة مدتها خمسة أيام
للقضاء تمامًا على كل الفيروس ، لذا
يصبح السؤال إذن هل يجب علينا
تمديده إلى سبعة إلى عشرة أيام أم إيريك توبول  في
معهد سكريبس يبحث الآن في
هذا الأمر ، فلديه تمويل غير قانوني للنظر في هذا
الأمر ، لذا سنتعلم الكثير ، نعم ، أعتقد
أن الأسئلة الآن أعتقد أن
الرئيس آه آمل أن يستمر في العمل
بشكل جيد ، هناك سؤال عما إذا كان
يجب أن يذهب  بالعودة إلى دورة أخرى من pax
loafed ، سيكون هناك الكثير من
المناقشات الشيقة في الأيام التالية